اتهم الدكتور قرقاش قطر من قبل
اللجنة الرباعية التي كانت الإمارات
أه كانت عضوا فيها من بين أمور أخرى
بالسلوك الاستفزازي والعدائي المتمثل في
رعاية أو دعم الإرهاب
والتدخل في شؤون
الدول المجاورة ، فهل أنت
واثق من أن هذه القضايا الرئيسية
كانت  تم حلها جيدًا مرة أخرى ،
تعلم أننا وضعنا ثقتنا
في السعوديين في قيادة هذه
العملية من المفاوضات وأعتقد أن
ثقتنا لها ما يبررها
ومن الواضح أيضًا
أن الفكرة أساسًا هي محاولة وضع
قواعد عدم التدخل في الاتفاق على
القضايا
التي تؤثر  كل منا بما في ذلك
التطرف والإرهاب
جزء لا يتجزأ من الفعل
نحن واثقون من أننا نتطلع إلى الأمام
بحماس أه لكن تعلمون كما
تعلمون دائمًا الدليل في
الحلوى ونأمل أن نعمل معًا
للمضي قدمًا على
يقين من أن ذلك  صدع تخريبي
مررنا به جميعًا أه
لا يجب أن يتكرر بالشفافية
ومن خلال العمل معًا
أه ل  معالجة هذه القضايا ما
حدث لقائمة الطلبات الـ 13 التي
وافقت عليها الرباعية بما في ذلك على
سبيل المثال
إغلاق قناة الجزيرة وإغلاق
قاعدة عسكرية تركية وتقليص تعاون الدوحة
مع إيران ، هل تم إسقاط هذه المطالب
الآن
سيدي جيدًا مرة أخرى أه مجددًا  وجهة نظري
وهذا شيء
قلناه دائمًا
أن المطالب الـ 13 في ذلك الوقت كانت
تعتبر ما يمكن أن أسميه
تفاوضًا متطرفًا
أعتقد أن ما ينتهي بنا الأمر إلى التعامل معه هو
الخطوط العريضة العامة التي تحكم
العلاقات بين الدول الأطراف
في  نفس المنظمة
الخليجية وفي حالة مصر أيضًا عضو
في الدوري العربي ،
لذا فهذه هي ما يمكنني
تسميته الخطوط العريضة العامة لكيفية
استمرار هذه العلاقة وأعتقد أننا راضون جدًا عن
هذا ونريد البناء عليه  ونريد
أن ننظر
إلى المستقبل للبناء على هذا
والتأكد من
أن
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في هذه المنطقة المضطربة للغاية تكون أكثر صلابة
وتوحيدًا وتتطلع إلى المستقبل
نحن
في انسجام تام